Hello,
I'm Zina Berdahl.
We welcome to the magnificent concert
hall here in Stockholm where this year's
Nobel prize winners received their
awards from the king of Sweden.
The Nobel prizes are amongst the most
prestigious accolades anywhere in the
world.
And this is the first time that this
year's Nobel laureates or repairing
together on television.
They're joined by their friends and
family who are taking part in the
celebrations.
And we also have an invited audience of
students from here in Sweden.
We'll be hearing and whether these Nobel
Prize winners believe that scientists
should be playing more of a role in
tackling the big problems of the day.
So here we are gentlemen,
and you are of course all gentlemen
because sadly,
Alice Munro,
the Nobel laureate for literature this
year couldn't join us,
but congratulations to all of you.
Um,
what were y'all doing briefly when you
heard the news?
Professor Randy Schekman.
Wow.
I was deep asleep,
but my wife heard the phone and she
blurted out,
this is it.
This is it.
I picked up the phone and I heard a soft
Swedish voice.
And although I'm not a religious person,
I blurted out,
oh my God.
And you knew that.
That really was it.
Um,
I think you were making your famous
banana toast for your grandchildren.
I see that the banana toast all had
these seven things,
which is,
and they know it's good to have to pay
to get the recipe.
Yeah.
I go up to a lot of letters asking me
for the recipe for the banana toe,
the prominent ones that I was there with
my three daughters.
The events of course could happen this
year,
but you know,
the clock went down home,
uh,
November 20 one.com.
He's doubled number close to zero and a
whoa.
There no phone calls or he or my
daughters were there.
And a day Ted dropped off.
Nasty thing about the Nobel Committee.
You know,
you will forever be remembered for the
banana toast when then you go down in
his role.
We do do,
do the banana
fellow laureates in physics,
Professor Peter Higgs.
Um,
you famous,
you don't have a mobile phone.
I do.
In fact put,
only my family knew the number.
Ah,
that's it.
So the Nobel Committee didn't.
So how did you find out?
Well,
I found out when I was walking back
home,
I'd left home late morning because
although I wasn't intending to avoid
hearing the announcement,
I was intending to avoid these
subsequent to me dear attention.
So I made sure that I was somewhere else
for lunch.
And I went to an Arctic submission
afterwards and we walked home about
three o'clock.
As I was walking home,
a former neighbor stopped her car across
the street,
came across to me and said,
congratulations,
but my,
my daughter's just phone from London and
told me the news about the award.
And I said,
what award?
And she told me,
so just a woman pastor by gave you the
good news and call my neighbor.
Oh,
I say former neighbor.
There you are.
A professor area.
Well,
so you,
you are one of the prize winners for
chemistry.
Um,
what were you doing?
Okay,
I took a half ambien to prevent,
to Elton flow,
the opposite news.
So it was snipping very deeply.
And then my wife woke me up again,
like landed when I held the Swedish
accent.
And few people in the background.
Did you get back to sleep afterwards?
No,
the newest people already camps.
Okay.
I'm Jim Raffman.
Well,
uh,
I was sleeping,
the phone rang.
I picked it up and I immediately dropped
it and it was dark and there were two
buttons to push,
you know,
the green one and the red one.
And when you get a call at that hour,
you kind of know what it's likely to be.
So which one was it?
And you know,
if you push the right one,
maybe you've got a Nobel prize.
He pushed the wrong one.
Okay.
Did they call back?
I pushed wine and I was very lucky.
The right,
it's a lot of luck to get a Nobel prize.
Absolutely.
Well,
a lot of hard work too.
We'll talk about that in a moment.
In medicine and physiology prize you,
I,
one of the winners,
Thomas suit up.
I think we were driving somewhere.
I have,
it's flown from San Francisco to Spain
the night before.
I had arrived early morning and my blood
went to the car,
was trying to find a somewhat obscure
little city,
Beautiful City called Pacer.
Wasn't happy because I couldn't find the
place phone rings thought it was my
colleague widely assumed I was lost.
Uh,
I wasn't actually even the Swedish
accent because they never reached me.
It was Adam Smith who is the British
accent the British hasn't put and who
works for Nova Media and who thought I
knew,
which I didn't.
And as a result,
my leaf call that phone call,
uh,
sort of
documents.
Yeah.
Documents.
My next you got the news in deepest
Spain and I'm a professor,
Robert Shiller,
one of the economics.
Um,
don't want to sound too intimate,
but you're in the bathroom.
Yeah,
I was,
you're catering to leave for a
conference in Phoenix,
Arizona.
And I was stepping out of the shower and
the phone rang and I thought maybe I'll
just let it ring because it's too
difficult to get to the phone that I
thought about the,
actually thought about the Nobel prize
and I thought,
well that is a chance.
So I went and answered it.
Um,
and I was pleasantly surprised.
Can I spell it?
Very happy moment.
And your fellow laureate for economics,
Eugene Farmer,
you're famous in early riser and the
students here will be very impressed to
hear that you were doing what?
I was listening to Don Pasquale and do
my back exercises,
but then I was had to prepare my class
after that,
so thank you.
And um,
I didn't come to you Michael it,
um,
but do you tell the son what you were
doing?
Were you also in bed
chemistry?
It's of course in California it was a to
16.
I had gone to sleep an hour before,
so that was pretty much asleep.
Um,
what was interesting about the core,
it's not just the Swedish accent,
there's a lot of,
uh,
I guess a trick call people call you on
that day at that time and say you've
just won the Nobel prize.
And last year,
apparently this had happened to somebody
the night before.
So this time we actually ask you a
question.
They tell you things that only they
could know.
Like we got drunk in Italy because as
soon as I had the news,
I ran.
And before I even updated my facebook
entry,
I called my mother
who your mother and I have to mention
actually,
I hope she won't mind.
So my saying Gertrude levied at 98,
you have traveled here to Sweden to join
a celebrations with your son.
Professor.
Love it.
Can we,
uh,
I think she just
[inaudible] is wonderful.
Now I want to ask you some questions.
Let's start with the economics.
Are Lawyers,
uh,
professor [inaudible] and professor
format for those of us trying to
understand how that last financial
crisis happened and uh,
worried about the next one.
Just give us an overview.
How far does your research help us do
that?
Professor shooter?
Well,
you're coming into a big disagreement.
Lost lawyers agree on most things.
You,
you've honed right in.
And then where gene and I disagree.
Now I actually predicted the crisis in a
second addition to my book.
I believe that smart people can
partially predict the market and why
shouldn't they?
I think it's,
it takes like anything else,
but you have to remember that you're
predicting human behavior.
It involves a kind of broad judgment of
bubbles,
speculative behavior and people.
Okay.
I should say I'm professor farm.
I mean I should just remind people
broadly speaking along with the lost
Peter Hansen who side,
they could not be with us because he's
not well you were awarded the prize
jointly for launching hundred in
thinking to show that prices are very
hard to predict in the short term and
even harder in the long term.
So professor Fama,
what's your answer to the questions?
Can economists help us predict and avoid
financial?
That's true about me.
Use the right words.
I believe that's the state of it,
but I've looked at the records
systematically and tried to test for it.
You cannot find it in the traces of the
data.
Um,
so that's where we
great.
Okay.
So what were you way on evidence about
statistical evidence about predictive?
There's a difference in perspective.
Now I'm married to a psychologist.
Maybe that's part of the reason he
always blames his way,
I believe in the unity of knowledge.
And I think there are so many things
outside of economics that people have to
wait.
Psychology,
sociology,
anthropology,
political science,
and now we're getting new thing.
Neuropsychology.
Well,
well,
yeah,
these,
the what separates us is it
interpretation of human nature and about
the importance of the individual and the
state things that are,
and that's why,
although I think we are both scientists
and agree on some facts,
it's the interpretation that different
gene Fama is one of the most successful
stock market predictors in the world.
He misinterprets,
he says I'm his,
he has dimensional fund advisors,
which is,
can I say this?
Managing $350 billion.
Huge Fun.
Why is he so why did these people come
to him?
Because he can predict the market,
not perfectly,
but well enough yet to outperform many
other f Eric and he's [inaudible] to me
is a science who knows how to predict
the murder.
He just won't admit it.
Well now you've brought up the subject
of money.
So let me,
let me,
let me explain.
I've made a fortune out of predicting
what will my students crisis and they've
been kind enough to come with me.
Handsome wafer professor should have
that.
His theories,
right,
but it's not psychology.
He can hate me.
I explain it.
Oh,
what this company does is it,
it,
it uh,
forms portfolios.
They concentrate on particular kinds of
risks.
So it's well understood that stocks are
riskier than bonds.
So if I phone or portfolio of stocks,
I can predict it in the long term that
will out likely outperform bonds.
In that sense,
the market is predictable.
That's what he's saying.
Okay.
But I don't think you can,
you can predict whether the stock market
is going to do something,
but that's a different story.
I mean,
there's a lot of debate here about
economic students,
particularly in the UK.
We've got this debate wanting to be
engaged in policy debates.
We have one,
a professor of economics at London
University who said,
you know,
my students are flipping the pages of
best sellers in economics.
They want to get involved in policy
debates.
They're not happy with what they're
getting in class because they feel they
know better equipped to interpret what's
going on.
Then students of archeology for
instance.
Do you believe it is your role as
professors of economics to teach your
undergraduates in your postgraduates how
to better understand the world of
finance?
Well I absolutely,
yeah.
I think Jane and I are actually similar
in that weird real world oriented and
Jean,
although his,
you wouldn't know it.
Listening to him,
he's had a huge impact on the way
finances practice and it's very helpful.
He's done a lot.
Very generous isn't to your fellow nor
yet.
I didn't use often that you get to at
Psu who'd been awarded the prize but a
different interpretation and yet one is
still very generous like that in a,
in his comments.
Students,
I want to ask you,
I know you want students of signs,
but does any of this resonate with you
in terms of the kinds of lessons that
your getting from your professors?
Do you feel that it equips you to
understand what's going on in the wild,
in your own particular disciplines?
Any comments,
fees?
In the students?
Yes.
I think there's a comment here.
As a physicist,
a undergraduate student,
we are taught to analyze data in a real
world environment,
uh,
famous experiments and around the world,
like the large Hadron collider in
Geneva.
So I definitely think that,
uh,
our,
our schooling and education applies to
larger big world pictures for sure.
Okay.
Other comments on this point?
I think there's a lady here.
I,
I'm not a economics in economics either.
I'm a neuroscientist,
but we're taught to problem solve and
think critically and that should help in
solving many problems that we're faced
with.
Thank you.
I think there's one more just,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm also a science student and I really
think I've learned in the last year on
my master or eh,
the caters real tries us to think
critically and understand the world,
but you also understand after five years
that is really complex.
Okay,
thank you.
Well,
um,
I think that kind of sets the scene a
little bit forwards to move into the,
um,
into the scientists and,
there's an underlying theme here.
Do you,
should you as scientists teach the kinds
of signs that will help us address,
you know,
the big problems of the day,
Jim Raffman,
by equipping students with the skills of
rigorous analytical thinking,
of taking a problem,
breaking it down to component parts,
asking which parts are are,
are solvable,
which ones can't be solved today,
and then directing you referred
appropriately.
That way of thinking can be,
it is the basis for solving problems of
any kind,
whether they're of immediate import or
whether they're problems we don't even
know about today.
That's what an education is.
That what you're saying is,
as you said in your speech when you
received the Nobel prize,
it's a curiosity driven research.
It's not research that's driven solving
a specific problem.
It's [inaudible]
basically can never predict,
and I think we all agree on this,
they could almost never predict where
something will lead in all of our work.
There are examples of basic science that
we've achieved in our laboratory,
in our theoretical work that have
applications that one couldn't have
imagined in my own work.
Uh,
what I did was a very basic problem in
how proteins are transported in yeast
cells,
which turns out having application and
liver cancer and ways that I couldn't
have imagined.
Yeah.
But I mean,
your research or medicine or physiology
helps us with the knowledge of a huge
range of illnesses,
diabetes,
brain disorders.
But I should also say botox.
I mean,
Botox obviously it has a magical purpose
because it helps people with that.
As I said in my remarks last night,
my colleagues,
Rothman and sit half figured out how
nerve cells communicate with one
another.
It turns out that,
uh,
botulism the disease,
works by producing a toxin that,
uh,
inactivates protein molecules that they
worked on.
And then that,
that has applications in a lot of
things.
Cosmetic word,
uh,
or neuromuscular disease.
No,
I have not used it myself,
but I don't think I need it just yet.
Yeah.
Okay.
Next to Terry,
professor check,
like,
I think we want to go to one of our
students here.
A question about physics.
Yes,
I am from the Royal Institute of
Technology.
And that was wondering what do you
think?
Yeah.
Or what kinds of technological
applications do you think will come from
the discovery of the Higgs Boson?
It,
let's go to prosser.
Professor Peter Higgs.
Yes.
Okay.
I don't know of any applications.
You're,
you're asking about how you would make
you to have something which has been
discovered,
which,
uh,
you,
you have to put,
you have to go to a lot of energy into
the making obit and then it lasts for an
extremely short time.
Uh,
how,
how can you do,
do anything useful with,
with that?
It's true.
Uh,
it,
it's true that,
uh,
politicals which have been discovered
previously,
some of them have applications in
medicine for example,
but they're relatively long lived
particles by our person's standards.
Uh,
things which even when they were
addressed,
maybe lost about a micro second.
And if you,
if you make the move fast and relatively
t tells you that they'll last longer and
you can make beams and you can use them
in,
in a cancer therapy and that sort of
thing.
Well that's okay for that kind of
political,
but,
but when you exploring this extremely
high energy range where the things you
produce just don't last very long,
it's hard to how you could
actually control them and hears them.
Okay.
Professor on glow,
you shared the prize with,
with Professor Higgs for the physics,
for the theory that explains why the
tiny particles that make up atoms have
mass.
I want to be frank with you.
I want to ask you,
the student,
they're mentioned the fact that it's
called the higgs based on theory.
Everybody says including Professor
Higgs,
that it should more accurately be known
as the b e h particle.
The Robert Route who is unfortunately
was not able to receive the prize
because he died,
but it should be known as the Brown on
glare.
Higgs particle.
Does it annoy you that it's known as the
Higgs Particle?
No.
You did what?
You did my miles.
Can you this question?
Okay.
Put the wrinkles,
but I am not.
The way you want to solve this.
Um,
I've got was,
it annoys me just because it's not the
public of the whole,
the so called his mom was on the chairs
first not being introduced by age.
That's one thing.
Although I have a complete admiration
for his work,
uh,
what should put things right,
but the media have a role in calling it,
well particular the Anglo Saxon fuse is
sometime physics was kind of Taco game
know due to poor mode for even sun.
That's how also money things in bulk,
right.
The,
the contribution of English is
important.
Sorry.
But,
and they have another teams,
right?
They detect the particular.
Okay.
And uh,
so,
uh,
I guess one sentence since on their
detection and they're quite tight and
they need money for that.
When I professor [inaudible] haven't
paid because I didn't answer your
question.
I thought you were on,
no,
no.
Okay.
I think they have been many b,
which are played the whole before the
theory was remade and people who have
made things after the theory is made and
as usual,
this is complete nonsense to give the
name of a person,
any person in a group setting,
if it's not the right one,
it's it.
But,
uh,
I think it's reasonable to give all the
particle a letter and personally.
Okay.
All right.
But
I would propose that letter the age.
Ah,
what do you think?
And then that final suggestion,
take your name off Higgs Boson and just
call it the letter h h theory.
Anyway,
your response.
I would be very happy with that solution
because the person's situation
embarrasses me.
Uh,
I think,
yeah.
Why does it embarrass you?
Well,
because it's,
it's,
it's come about so accidentally.
It's not a,
not a recognition of,
of,
uh,
but I,
I,
I was any sort of special,
uh,
personal in this is story though.
There were many people involved as far
as wise as I said.
And it's,
it's,
it's so happened that my name has been
attached to it for a number of
accidental reasons.
Uh,
and uh,
that's unfair to the other people
involved.
I'd like to make a distinction between
the particle and what is called the
mechanism,
which is how to,
how would you get mass rather particles.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm happy with the solution which is now
becoming common in particle physics
world to call it the b h mechanism.
And that's to me the,
the,
the really the important part of the
Siri,
uh,
the,
the particle,
it's soul should not carry anybody's
name and the solution of giving it the
letter h because in the past my name has
been attached or it is,
is a good one.
But the,
okay,
well we'll leave,
we'll leave that particular exchange
there and um,
the student,
next time you ask your question,
be careful what you call it was very,
that's what I'm saying.
It will be professor Thomas Uhthoff.
You,
you have one of the joint winners of the
medicine physiology prize.
I just want to ask you what you think
about the application of your particular
theories.
Does it matter to you that your
discoveries for your work on um,
vesicles and I won't go into too much,
but they kind of are an act as the
cells,
internal shipping,
um,
service or postman,
they can send materials around the
settle can even fuse with its outer
surface.
But how important was it for you when
you were doing your research that this
would actually help perhaps save lives?
Uh,
I was afraid you were going to ask me
about the Hicks puzzle.
I think in a common theme in science is
we do science best we made on have an
application in mind because of the
limits,
our imagination and creativity.
But in the end we feel mostly watered
when what we discover out of a quest for
knowledge leads actually to an
application.
And so what I do,
and I think what my fellow laureates
too,
I think it's extremely important for us
to find that,
I wouldn't call it an accident,
but serendipity,
what we do actually is useful.
Is it,
is it a motivating factor for all of you
in your research or do you just see it
as a bonus
professor level?
What I would say is that,
uh,
and to use an economic inc similarly
here,
this is that a research that is longer
term is much,
much larger pay off.
And in some senses I think that this
sort of fits into what,
uh,
when you were saying you don't want to
think about solving tomorrow's problems
today,
you want to solve about problems that
haven't even been designed yet and then
you'll have a massive impact.
And I think this is a very critical
thing because we are increasingly
wanting to solve short term problems.
And I think it is perhaps high energy
physics doesn't have a very direct
practical application,
but it's really hard to imagine the
applications that are going to come up.
Yeah.
The long views and I mean the,
these gentle recognize decades later
from the work they actually did.
I mean James Rothman just picking up
this point about research and the long
view and so on.
I mean,
would you be happy if you are a young
scientist starting out today trying to
embark on some research which needed
funding?
Well,
I'd be very happy if I was a young
scientist.
I wouldn't be an old science,
but,
uh,
you know,
I think it,
we're,
we're in a very challenging era before
for the very reasons that we heard a
moment ago from,
from Michael.
There's an increasingly,
uh,
increasing effort on the short term
short term success and it causes young
scientists to take less in the way of
risk and to do more research.
That's more incremental small step here,
a small step,
they're more likely to reap a short term
reward.
But,
uh,
those of us around the table today,
I think each in our own way,
we're taking on problems that were very
challenging in our time quite some time
ago.
We all feel an enormous increase in
pressure from public institutions or
rather from politicians and the public
foundations,
patient advocates,
whatever,
to do science that will lead to tangible
results tomorrow.
Sure.
This cure that now and in my view that
never works because you can't cure
something you don't understand and our
case physiology on dre or medicine
Professor Rochelle,
Samuel first try to solve problems which
are really difficult like how enzyme
work Indo case,
what is the mass in the universe and
eventually some of the solutions has
application in lily to your question,
what is missing in all of this is
teaching politicians in the university,
people who will become politician to
understand some concepts in science.
So in the future they will be able to do
better.
Making
this is this is something important that
we all should be better educated in
science by examination.
It seems to me that I don't know if this
is necessary because I can go require a
very narrow minded politician to say
that size hadn't had a massive effect on
everything we do over the last hundred
years.
It seems to me that the general,
you know,
maybe none targeted investment in
science that we've had at say,
let's just say since the Second World
War has paid off,
unbelievably the living standard,
you know,
maybe that's where we have so many
people on earth,
but it's all part of the success of
science.
So it seems to me that we don't have to
justify every little
12 point that Professor Walsh and made
about,
um,
might suppose you're basically saying
scientific illiteracy,
but people need to be better educated,
public politicians.
I mean,
it's scientific illiteracy,
more acceptable than other forms of
relief.
I have thought about that a lot.
If I said,
uh,
oh Shakespeare,
who cares about him?
You don't think my God.
But if somebody says a billion,
a million,
what difference does it make?
You know,
that's a pretty big error.
People need to learn much more
statistically.
I know,
I think there is a check when,
and then she has a tremendous ignorance
of science in the u s which
unfortunately is fostered by the
political process right now.
We have,
uh,
a great deal of disbelief.
It basic scientific principles in the
United States that drives the,
uh,
politics.
There's a dismissal of evolution.
There's a disbelief in climate change,
in spite of the overwhelming evidence.
So w w we have to do a better job.
It used to be that the government,
you know,
I've been the beneficiary of this,
we have all been the beneficiary of an
investment in science starting with,
uh,
the end of World War II with the sputnik
era in the United States.
It was enormous investment.
It's science,
science education that's diminished
particularly in the public.
So it's not happening now.
You don't think science is getting
funding sufficient,
not enough.
And,
and,
and then what,
what is funded is being managed more,
much more so than it used to be.
I said Shit.
Huh?
As an economist,
I would like to point out that
scientific research provides a public
good that benefits the entire world.
So one country,
let's take Sweden.
Politicians here would rationally think,
why should we pay for it?
The rest of the world will do it anyway.
If we pay 1 million kroner for some
research project,
only a tiny part of that will benefit
Sweden.
It'll go all over the world.
So part of the defense of scientific
research has to be a cosmopolitan
publix,
what professor said have said,
which is that you scientists have to
communicate better with the public and
politicians about what it is you are
doing.
But we have a question I think from one
of the students here about this subject.
Yup.
Ricard the Gui,
the Karolinska Institute.
So I wonder if you think that,
do scientists communicate bad leaders
science?
How do we avoid the misunderstanding and
gain a better presence on public debates
on this point of communication?
Uh,
professor farmer economists obviously
is,
is not a pure science,
your social scientists,
but you are asked to comment every hour,
every day of the week because of the
financial crisis and so on.
Do you think you make a good job of
communicating with the public?
I don't think we make it clear and
distinguishing between the things we
know based on research that had been
done and opinions that we have based on
our own interpretation of things.
I don't think we do a good job on that.
I think too many economists are willing
to talk too much about things that they
really don't know a lot about.
Um,
I try to avoid that immature mentality
successful.
Uh,
and they do lots of media interviews
yourself,
asked to predict what is going on.
And so we're actually,
before he got the Nobel prize and nobody
was much interested in me,
then afterward they became interested
in,
I said I didn't change.
I'm still a dumb guy.
You thought I was two months ago.
Professor Sheila,
you do interact a lot with apartment.
You've written books which are supposed
to be accessing if a student as it's on
that you write books,
which is supposed to be accessible to
even people who haven't started
economics.
What's your view on how economists
communicate with the public?
But I think that economists have been
too much in the science model of
writing.
Concise,
Short.
I mean there's some of that is good
concise,
short journal articles that make a very
narrow but frontier contribution that we
model ourselves after a physics
particularly I think.
But I think there's an older,
a different tradition that's also
valuable and that is writing books that
draw together theory and practice and
the,
and the profession tends to,
if you say,
I've written a book that is rare,
they think,
oh that's a,
they call it a popular realization,
but I don't think that some of these
books that are,
why are they red,
are popular realizations at all there.
Their synthesis that can operate at a
level of an ordinary intelligence.
She's online as well.
You provide lectures.
Yeah,
you can take my car,
but you also provide lectures online.
I think that,
uh,
in the last say 50 years,
communication has undergone an
incredible revolution.
And at the time when,
you know,
facebook has been phased out for
twitter,
which has been phased out for a snapshot
or whatever,
it seems to me that the only way we can
communicate thing is not to communicate
with people in their forties,
even if the way is the community.
It was people in their teens and early
twenties.
And it seems to me that everyone here
should be on facebook
freely accessible to non students as
students ever won a science.
Let's just,
um,
get some feedback here.
Who thinks that scientists do a good job
of communicating with the public and I
see people their hands up who thinks,
does scientists do a good job of
communicating with the public?
Do you think scientists do a bad job of
communicating with the public
mine
who thinks that these Nobel laureates
have been doing a good job of
communicating it?
So know you've got a good,
you got a good response to that.
I just asked you whether you feel that
sometimes scientists are running ahead
of what society both understands and
thinks is acceptable and without going
into various examples here,
it's really a question about the
potential misuse of your discoveries or
a potential lack of understanding of
what your discoveries may bring about.
I mean,
there are so many examples.
I'm thinking of the Belgian geneticist
who,
who brought about gm who says that
Professor Montague,
Mark Van Montague,
who says that society fears science
because it upsets the traditional way of
living.
Do any of you worry at night about how
your various discoveries may be misused
in the future?
Sure.
To turn the question just a bit,
I think there is an overselling our part
sometimes of what science can do and
just use an example,
the war on cancer in the 1970s under
President Nixon real,
it really wasn't,
it wasn't an enormous investment.
A lot of science was done,
but cancer was not cured.
We shouldn't over promise what we can
deliver.
Is there overhype professor said hop on
the part of scientists.
Absolutely.
I think that communicating with the
public,
that's probably one of the biggest
mistakes we are scientists have made
because we haven't communicated the
magnitude of the challenge.
We haven't communicate how difficult it
is.
For example,
don't understand a cancer cell or to
understand the brain and people expect
us to solve this and to have solutions
tomorrow and that's our fault.
Why do you think that happens?
Because we claim to make discoveries as
a community that aren't there.
And do you think you're asked the wrong
questions sometimes or pushed into
saying things you shouldn't say by the
media?
There's no doubt about that.
It's blaming the media again.
Absolutely.
No question.
Yeah.
I think one of the DP guilty,
the communication of tides is the basic
education to begin with.
Do you see either sense?
Maybe you can try to give a vague idea
to,
uh,
to people about how they can be cured
about some cancer.
Then they may understand something,
right?
But if you try to explain something
which is deeper,
I don't want to make a deeper,
I mean basic far right,
which is the,
then they don't have any mathematical
basis to understand this.
And the difficulty comes already from
the first year.
No,
I said at the start that you are all
gentlemen.
Obviously Alice Munro won the prize for
literature and one of the chemistry
laureates,
Martin Karplus can't be with us,
but obviously another man.
What is it about science and women check
when Michael Levitt?
I think the problem is with the age
group of the gentleman here.
Uh,
we,
we all did our work.
I mean,
the work that I was credited for,
I did as an assistant professor.
That was back at a time when there were
few women.
In fact,
there were no women in my department.
There are many more women that we hire
now.
So,
uh,
I look forward to in 30 years,
you'll still be just as young
interviewing,
uh,
a number of women.
I like you and still no botox,
Professor Higgs,
lack of women.
Well
and my kind of physics,
there are interesting differences
between different countries,
at least at least within Europe.
Um,
until I went to Italy,
I think my prejudice would have been
that the,
uh,
the,
the southern Catholic countries,
we're less likely to have women
scientists in the northern mostly
Protestant countries because of the
attitudes of the Catholic Church to what
women ought to be doing.
It isn't.
So it's the other way round.
Uh,
it's,
it's Italy which has the largest
proportion of women in physics and the
northern countries do rather badly by
comparison.
That's a very interesting point you
raise there professor higgs because
Sweden,
which is famous for its very efficient
and effective childcare system actually
has a very low number of professors
right across the board.
Not only in science,
it's only about 21%.
Since we have some students from here,
universities in Sweden.
What do you think about this gender is
to,
uh,
I would like to comment on what
Professor Haig said that religion has
some impact on this.
And I think in earlier generation,
the head nowadays,
we can look at this room is full of
women.
We are gaining power and we are starting
to do science,
but we still have to take a lot of risks
and to do a lot of difficult choices.
For example,
I had to move from my country because
the maternity's and s and those problems
in my country,
there's still problematic.
That's why I moved to northern country.
Which country?
You are from?
Portugal.
Portuguese.
Okay.
Another person,
another science student.
I'm in a social sciences which is full
of women and in the social worker who
was this even more women and still in
Sweden we have men that are on the top
of the Eh,
the top positions in both society and
science,
so that must reflect something.
Even when there is basically all the
women in the field,
usually what you do,
you have kids as a male and the female
and accepts the pregnancy,
which usually people are only way maybe
for a few weeks.
The kids is something you get together
and say if it's a female problem,
you should also be a main problem.
Right?
Student?
Yes.
I see somebody there.
Thank you.
Phd Student and molecular biology.
There are a lot of women in science now
as someone else's plan it out.
And I don't think that there are less
opportunities for women in science.
I think that if you want to have a
family and a career,
that's your choice.
And I think that there are many examples
of successful women's science.
Science has to,
I've made it happen.
Maybe not sitting at the table today,
but maybe they'll be sat at the table in
the future.
And I,
I think that the future have,
will reflect that.
But I think that the opportunities are
there,
but that's around you shut your not only
concerned about encouraging women to
study science,
you want to ensure that everyone from
all walks of life can have access to a
university.
I'm very,
I'm very concerned about public higher
education.
That may not be as much an issue in
Sweden,
but in the United States,
the individual states have decreased
their support,
supportive public,
higher education,
particularly.
Uh,
there's virtually an inverse
relationship between the funding of
prisons in the United States and the
funding of public higher education.
And I think this has been much to the
detriment of the middle class who
wouldn't necessarily have that in large
numbers,
have access to the elite institutions
that are represented around this table.
You disappointed,
very disappointed.
And I,
I came from a middle class family.
I could work a summer job and pay for
the whole year,
uh,
room board books that that is no longer
possible.
That's,
I think that is,
uh,
that is,
has damaged access to,
uh,
to the,
the highest reaches of science at least
in the United States.
Anybody else on this issue of access in
the UK?
Professor next,
we have a similar debate about it.
Similar situation where,
where,
I mean my generation,
a lot of public funding going to
universities and,
and there's a generation of,
of academics,
not just in science but other fields
who,
who came from all kinds of social
backgrounds.
But now it's been made much more
difficult by the present policies,
policies of introducing fees and uh,
people from poor backgrounds or simply
deterred from trying.
Are you worried that actually this
crisis in funding some countries is
going to jeopardize their future as
being centers of excellence where you
can get the kind of people like q who
come up with the discoveries and just
think about the fact that as far as I
understand sociological studies suggest
that social mobility
in the United States is now lower than
Europe and that sort of puts it on.
So we always used to be that social
mobility look at me and man,
uh,
in the United States was better than a
New York and now it's the opposite
center of excellence is going to move
back to move back to Europe as well as
that's possible.
But I hope that we'll move to Asia.
Asia you're already is.
Yeah.
Moving away from the United States,
not black and white,
you know,
but integrated way where it comes back
to research support,
it comes down to public education.
It comes down to a v a value system of,
of uh,
immediacy versus a longer term view.
And a and I think it going to,
well I think in part it's a lot,
a lot of it has gone already to Europe.
Europe had a tremendous task of
rebuilding after World War II.
Uh,
that's largely done in the sciences,
especially China.
China is it,
you know in Asia are very hungry to be
major players but they tend to be still
quite short term focus.
The China thinks in five year plans,
it's a 50 year plan.
If it's a plant,
any kind of a plan at all,
it's more like an intent.
And do you think there are certain
cultures that better encourage free
thinking,
the blue skies thinking that brings
about the great discoveries.
I was thinking that the United States
had a more public spirit after World War
II then it does now.
The Marshall Plan is an example of
something that happened to then that was
an aid program to Europe.
It wouldn't happen now.
And that the,
the,
the climbing support for education is
another example of that.
I wanted to remind us that we are here
at the legacy of Alfred Nobel who had a
tremendous public spirit and that's one
reason why the Nobel prize is a renewed
inspiration.
Talking about access,
you now have access to the air of the
powerful in the world.
Are you going to be using this new found
recognition that you have to put forward
the case that you'd be making about
greater access or any other issue?
I'll come to you,
professor love it
for,
I think it's really important to have an
issue after getting the Nobel prize.
You have to do something with the rest
of your life and besides science with
it,
I'll continue to do.
I think an issue for me that is really,
really worrying is that the the youth to
be people who have positions between the
ages of 20 and 40 and that whole
generation is slowly disappearing.
It's becoming very hard to become an
independent scientist.
If you're younger than 40 and you know,
30 or 40 years ago,
you could be in your early twenties.
I think that this is can be explained in
many ways sociologically,
but I think that it's as if you have
another one when you're finished
university here instead of getting a
position in five years,
it can take 15 years.
And I think this is a huge waste of
talent
because we see,
um,
talent,
young town bringing up things like
facebook,
you know,
you'd have to drop out of college even,
to have found Microsoft,
apple,
Google,
facebook,
Yahoo,
not a good sign.
It's a general society problem and
economic problem that things,
uh,
more and more seeing the possibility of
funding students to help them to go
[inaudible] in Belgium,
but it's very difficult otherwise.
Okay.
Very briefly,
anybody got any idea about how they're
going to be using the new influenced as
a Nobel laureate to in some way better
the world?
Not only as a scientist but beyond the
realm of science?
Professor Marshall,
did you have your hand up?
I will find it out eventually.
Professor Fama and I'm going to continue
to do what I've been doing.
My,
my,
my simple attitude is everything that
creates economic output adds to
humanity.
My plumber is perhaps as important as I
am.
I wish I had a good one,
but you may not.
This one may not be as important as
mine,
but everybody that contributes something
to output makes everybody else bigger,
better,
better off.
So I'm good at what I do.
Why would I try to do something I'm not
good at good at?
I think I can make the world better if I
continue what I'm doing.
Eugene Fama,
thank you very much and didn't
gentlemen.
Thank you all very much.
Well that brings this exclusive program
to an end.
We've heard what this year's Nobel
laureates have to say about the role of
science and Economics in today's
society.
We've also heard from the students here
from Sweden,
um,
about what they think the road of
science should also be.
Who knows there may be a future Nobel
Prize winner amongst you all.
Thank you to the family and friends of
the lawyer,
to the lawyer.
It's themselves,
of course,
to you,
wherever you are for watching this
program from me.
Zainab [inaudible].
We're here in the concert hall in
Stockholm.
Goodbye.